welcome to my bedroom
[Music]
[Music]
this will be an official tour of my
paintings and most frighteningly my mind
and the psychology behind the art i make
some of which is
well you'll see i feel like i just don't
get to talk about art enough but i know
that i like warm deep colors and art
which kind of pretentiously means
something to me to me art is very very
important these pieces come with me
everywhere they're kind of an anchor for
my sanity and it takes a very long time
for me usually to decide what i want to
paint what i want to call it and what
this thing will symbolize all of my
current paintings are now in the
background of this video and most of my
videos and i've made them all in the
last
six years um there's not a lot because i
really don't get to paint as much as i
wish i could today i'm going to go
through them one by one what they are
called and what their meaning is and
kind of the background of why i created
this piece and how it was done so let's
get straight into it
we crawl out of the room surprised to be
alone is a quote by eddie and marie
brown which i think beautifully captures
this feeling of loneliness and sometimes
anguishing isolation that we can feel
especially when we are around others and
we feel alone but on the other hand i
always felt as though there was this
very beautiful thing captured in
solitude especially bodies of water
waves and the sea always had this power
to kind of capture me transport my mind
and make me feel so small and
insignificant and i always adored this
feeling the immediate perspective shift
i can get when i'm around the scene is
almost like a feeling of nature kind of
putting me in my place and showing me
how small i am and it kind of washes
away all my worries and it's so so so
liberating seeing as i'm quite rarely
actually around the sea in this little
square i wanted to capture a part of
that for me to see every single day and
with this painting in particular so it's
an oil painting i really liked it when i
first saw it because i feel as though
the movement is just perfect as this
moment before the wave crashes the
curvature of it the feeling that it
gives me almost as though i can hear the
wave as it's crashing down and also the
fact that the colors are really rich and
deep i adore i don't know if it's day or
night light or dark sad or happy so i
can interpret it either way every time
that i'm looking at it depending on how
i'm feeling so it really really
transports me somewhere very powerful
and that's why it's also called for your
eyes only it's meant to represent this
peaceful solitude
we all have the ability to make people
feel the way that we felt when we were
younger is such a powerful quote from dr
kirk conda because i think it really
shows that the impact of our childhood
and how that can affect us and i think
that when we're around people people
have a vibe they have a very easy
ability to make you feel a certain way
and that can oscillate wildly from
feeling almost abusive and negative to
something just feeling like tender
warmth and peace and i think that no
matter what our childhoods we're like
once we are adults i think that we have
a very strong responsibility to undo any
sort of trauma or damage that we were
given when we were younger and to make
the world a better place for ourselves
and for other people so the way that
this ties with this painting is that
this is a painting of venus which was
the goddess of beauty and love in
ancient greece and ancient rome and she
had an interesting birth story because
she was born in fully adult form so in
this painting as we see her she looks
like an adult but technically she's just
a baby because she's just arrived so
what this means to me is kind of the
view that even though i can see her as
being an adult
technically deep down she still has
those same needs for love and affection
and attention and these desires are the
same in everyone no matter how grown we
are and sometimes we kind of express
them in the same kicking screaming angry
way that babies can do and i think this
kind of helps me kind of give people the
benefit of the doubt that sometimes
their negative reactions might be just
because of these unmet childhood needs
which sometimes i can very easily forget
if i'm frustrated but on the other hand
it kind of reminds me to do that work
myself and to recognize these childhood
reactions in myself and to fulfill those
needs in healthier ways than the
negative ways that they might express
themselves as a piece itself it's
originally from bourgeois
i'm not sure but this is a huge
beautiful painting it has this
neoclassical feel to it so it's really
realistic it's really soft it's super
detailed none of which are true in my
specific painting but in the original
one they definitely are and i think it
really fits this aesthetic and vibe that
i really like and also the fact that it
has a woman on it kind of this
celebration of the female form in art i
think is so so amazing so i love it for
all of those reasons also ancient greek
mythology is very important to me
because i used to be obsessed with it as
a child so it's also a slight nod
towards that but in general it just
ticks all the boxes for what i adore in
paintings and the title of it the birth
of venus is just the original title from
the original painting
[Music]
in the library i felt better words you
could trust and look at until you
understood them they couldn't change
halfway through a sentence like people
so it was easier to spot a lie is a
beautiful quote by jeanette winters and
there's a beauty in art and reading that
i realized very early on but took me a
very long time to understand where it
came from i feel as though at the core
of it i just felt connected and it took
me a while to embrace the fact that i
felt as though i was conversing or close
to another human being and this human
being the writer or a protagonist in the
book might be someone who definitely
will never know that i ever existed
might be someone who has died hundreds
of years ago or it might be a character
who was fictional has never even existed
at all but yet they make me feel less
alone and they make me feel connected
with them in a certain way and this was
very very important to me the
philosopher proust also realized this
when he said it's almost as though we
imagine the epic poet to be as foreign
to us as an animal in a zoo and i think
that there's this constant separation
that we have between us and the world
we're living internally and we're
looking at things from our perspective
and feeling as though we're often
sometimes very alone but i think the
perspective that you can get through
looking at art or through reading a book
is kind of a window or a first-person
view in someone else's body and you
almost realize that this alien world is
very similar to your own and this
connection is so so so profound it also
therefore means that many more places in
the world almost feel like home because
they're much more familiar than the
isolation that we had before we accessed
them at some point in my life i just let
myself fall in love with it all fall in
love with the arts for love with books
we're in love with reading again gen
wilson responded to the question of does
she often fall in love with yes often
with a view with a book with a dog with
a cat with numbers with friends with
complete strangers with nothing at all
and so this painting captures that the
romance were the the love for the arts
um originally i think it is a photograph
that used to be in vogue but i saw it
and it just captured that moment and i
thought this is perfect because i've
been wanting something with this message
for a very long time so i thought i
really really had to make this painting
again like everything else it's also an
oil painting but i'm really really proud
of this one because i painted the face
for the first time in true colors or i
tried to get to true colors using
primary colors only so i mix the skin
tone myself and it's quite accurate and
for the very first time i managed to
paint an accurate skin tone so i'm super
proud of that and i think it's just
really well done i'm very proud of
myself um and it's kind of a lonely
painting and i think i definitely
painted it at time of my life where i
felt very isolated and by myself but um
i still stick with it i do love books i
do have art and this is one of my
favorite paintings of all time so yes
this is why it's called the statue of
liberty it is the freedom of realizing
that you can feel connected from things
that don't need to be other human beings
and other people
[Music]
there's always a place inside of you
which has never been hurt is a beautiful
quote by john donahoe and i think it is
so accurate for van gaal when van gogh
the original painter of this piece made
this painting it was after he had signed
himself into a mental health institution
after he's been struggling on enough
with his mental health for a very long
time and the fact that he could be in
potentially the lowest point in his life
and he could look out for the window and
go that's beautiful i i want to paint
that that shows that there's always a
part of us than an ability to remain
self-aware and to remain inspired and to
remain creative and to remain passionate
about the world and everything that we
see around us and this is something that
i always always aspire to especially my
lower moments i don't think i have his
strength but um i try to i chose to have
it and this painting sometimes reminds
me of this this is a very quick and easy
painting to do so if it resonates with
anyone i would really recommend trying
it out it's really good but one other
thing i want to say is that it's quite
weird for me to like this sort of art i
didn't used to like impressionist or
modern art and i used to really really
prefer neoclassical or classical art but
i've looked very recently at some of
vangos original paintings and my mind
was blown i think i just need to take a
moment to say it is super human you know
that all you have when you look at
something hyper realistic well you look
at van gaal's paintings and they look
even more incredible than the realistic
ones the amount of movement and there's
like thousands of shades of blue in this
original painting it's just absolutely
mental crazy 100 would recommend they
must be seen they're so so beautiful if
you ever get the chance we'll definitely
go and see his original work
[Music]
next we move on to my lockdown
collection and um slight warning this is
one that i struggle to explain to people
so let's see how that goes but um it's a
bit of a weird one you've you've been
told so let's get into it um firstly
this was a photograph that i saw
somewhere and i had to do a double take
and it made me
feel a bit weird and i didn't understand
why i thought is it uncomfortable am i
uncomfortable because this is old people
showing affection i potentially haven't
seen a lot of this why is this making me
feel a certain way so i guess kind of
like lines in detention i made myself
kind of sit down and do this painting so
i would get over the discomfort of
seeing affection and love in really old
people and i think it worked really well
that was that was very effective but
most importantly um the title of this
painting is called we believe in the
winter and i think it captures something
which is very essential and core to who
i am as a person we believe in the
winter is a phrase from a anecdote which
i really like and it's about two monks
who were staying at monastery and they
were really struggling to stay put they
wanted to quit and a lot of other monks
at this time were quitting too so what
these two mocks would tell each other
was every summer they would say we're
going to leave in the winter and every
winter they would say we are going to
leave in the summer and eventually they
never left they died in the monastery of
old age and they managed to stay there
this whole time while so many people
have quit and i think what this
represented to me was that the ability
to stay in the state that you are
currently in is perhaps better achieved
with a promise for future change rather
than kind of taking action in the moment
or on the other hand promising yourself
to nev relieve and i think that this
made me wonder if you know the cure to
commit to something is to promise
yourself that it's temporary because as
someone who really struggles with
commitment i thought that potentially
this would be a way to kind of
hack my brain or reverse psychology
myself into staying put or committing to
things longer term to think that oh it's
just temporary you're going to leave in
the winter um so yeah this is why i made
this painting i don't know if that made
sense to everyone else um when people
see it they're like oh this is really
cute eternal love i wish i could have
that and that's absolutely fine but um
to me it means that plus something even
deeper so hopefully i managed to explain
that if not sorry for the weirdness but
uh yeah let's move on
next we have trick of the light and this
is more of an exercise for me because i
am a massively impatient person most of
the paintings that you've seen so far
have been done in a single sitting i'm
the sort of person who just wants to sit
down i'll sit for 20 hours i don't need
food i just want to get this finished
because i can't get up until it's done
and then i can't move my shoulder for a
week but this has been the way that i
painted most of the time because i
recognized this and it was getting worse
and worse because i wanted to do very
detailed paintings and there's this one
drawing i've actually done i'll show it
on screen and it was done in one sitting
and i could not move my shoulder for two
weeks after um so i thought no this is a
problem so immediately after this
drawing of lions i went we're gonna have
to do a painting here and what i did was
i bought a really big canvas so this is
one of the biggest ones that i have and
i picked a really really detailed
painting so i could do it in multiple
sittings which i did manage to do um
this is also a nod towards kind of these
romantic warm colors i really like light
play and i've done a terrible job of
many things in this painting i think
this is when i realized i need to take
more time with um setting the form and
the drawing initially because i think
the proportions are off um i also used
white way too early in the painting
process so then i couldn't lift things
any higher basically light work not too
good proportions not too good but
overall it still gives a very warm nice
feminine vibe which i really adore and
the inspiration piece is from a
photograph from someone i really like i
don't remember his name i'll try to find
it and he has these wonderful
backstage runway shots that he just
captures so so so beautifully so it kind
of gives me this modern neoclassical
feel so absolutely love it i think in
conclusion i am not a huge fan of pacing
myself and doing things slowly that's
why when i painted my podcast i find it
really difficult to not do it all in a
sitting but i think i kind of proved
myself that i can slow down which 90 of
my comments ask me to do every single
video so yeah this was done slowly and i
think i can do it now but i think i'll
stick to my faster pieces in general
[Music]
lastly and my most recent piece is
gorgeous of beauty and this was done
during my podcast like we will leave in
the winter was also done this is also a
nod to classical greek mythology because
again it is a painting of venus and or
aphrodite i think it was an edited
photograph that i saw somewhere online
and i fell in love with because i think
it captured the ridiculousness of modern
beauty standards and the fact that even
greek goddesses by today's standards
would need some modifications and
plastic surgery to be conventionally
beautiful and it kind of shows this
inability for us to ever be beautiful
with any sort of standards and the fact
that on the other hand beauty is perhaps
everywhere i go into this in a lot more
detail in a podcast episode i'll link
below so i chat about this point for
about half an hour so if you want to
check that out there'll be a lot more
details but basically for me it kind of
captures the ridiculousness of trying to
abide fully by today's beauty standards
and the fact that there is perhaps
beauty in everything and also because
it's something that i've definitely
struggled with in my past i think it
kind of helps me process my feelings and
process my thoughts a lot better when i
capture that in a piece of art being as
i rarely actually find the time to sit
down and paint this video is an
interesting collaboration with click up
who promised to save everyone a day a
week which honestly i could really do
with
click up is a site which works
surprisingly well with my one girl team
as it does for super large teams and
it's basically an all-in-one workspace
the main reason i've currently turned to
it is for time tracking which is
something done in the app itself as my
edits and scripting are currently taking
way longer than is reasonable so i think
a little measure of what i'm doing and
when is in order and can hopefully help
me manage myself better if you also
struggle with having any clue how long
your tasks are taking and would love to
be more efficient and save time for the
things we truly love especially with
summer coming up you can set yourself up
for free with click up as a one person
team with my link below so yeah these
are all of my oil paintings i also have
kind of pencil drawings and i also have
a lot of digital artwork which is mostly
medical actually um that i've done but
these are the most important pieces to
me because they are physical and they
always create a vibe that i love in my
room so i think the combination of these
artworks some plants and books i think
is definitely my aesthetic i don't need
much else beyond that to make a room
feel like my own but yeah i hope that
this was entertaining in any shape or
form if you also enjoy art um i'm
currently in the process of picking my
next painting because i need to do a
season three of my podcast so that will
hopefully be coming soon but yeah thank
you so much if you made it so far i hope
you have a wonderful rest of your day
behind yourself and others and don't
believe everything you think thanks bye